diese Pasta ist ein absoluter tiktok
Klassiker
und das absolut zurecht wir machen Penne
aller Wodka zu allererst einmal gebe ich
meine penne in einen Topf Wasser ist
gesalzen selbstverständlich in unsere
Pfanne ein wenig Olivenöl als nächstes
brauchen wir eine gehackte Schalotte
Charlotten kommen in die Pfanne als
nächstes Schnippe ich Knoblauch und den
geben wir Zeit versetzt dazu es riecht
einfach direkt lecker als nächstes
Tomatenmark der ist tomatisieren wir das
ganze jetzt kommt der Wodka zum Einsatz
einfach zum Ablöschen drüber gießen
wenn der verkocht ist geben wir Sahne
dazu und gehen dann auch direkt ein
bisschen runter mit der Hitze jetzt
rühren und die Sahne einreduzieren bis
wir eine sämige Soße haben als nächstes
folgt ein bisschen Salz und Chiliflocken
darf ruhig ein bisschen scharf sein so
Köche das ganze jetzt ein bisschen vor
sich hin bis unsere Nudeln fertig sind
Nudeln sind fertig und es darf ruhig
noch ein bisschen Nudelwasser dran sein
wenn wir sie zu der Soße geben so jetzt
in Deckung gehen
fertig sind die Penne aller Wodka noch
schön Parmesan drüber und eins kann man
auf jeden Fall sagen